we're well into 2021 so the electric
vehicle revolution isn't just on the
horizon it's here the effects of climate
change and our need to reduce our
dependence on fossil fuel burning cars
is something we've been talking about
for decades even governments around the
world are passing legislation to limit
or ban petrol and diesel cars within the
next decade with huge names like tesla
and lucid coming out with the best in
battery range and luxury the growth of
the ev is clear to see but that doesn't
mean there aren't significant challenges
in the industry from high maintenance
fees and range anxiety to potential
security issues these are some of the
biggest issues evs face today too high
tech there can be such a thing as too
much technology although evs aren't the
only cars that can be hacked they are
more vulnerable to attacks the problem
is evs are increasingly high tech which
leaves more opportunities for hackers as
more electric cars are connected to the
internet they get easier and easier to
discover an attack and it's not just a
data breach or getting your car stolen
you need to worry about we're talking
about tons of metal here which can be
steered remotely and potentially cause
massive destruction to public property
and also you know injure or kill people
and this isn't a far-fetched idea it was
shown to be possible when a chinese
company had to tesla model s in 2016.
well tesla has fixed that problem now
but for how long the continuous clash
between the hackers and manufacturers
means the risk of being hacked will
always be there maintenance let's keep
costs aside for a minute how many
mechanics in your area deal with
electric cars although evs generally
require less maintenance if your ev has
been caught in an accident you'll
probably need to visit a workshop and
it's very likely you won't be able to
tow your car to your neighborhood garage
well if you live in a place where
everything comes right to your doorstep
like dubai that's not such a problem but
then there's the matter of exorbitant
fees evs require less maintenance
because they have fewer moving parts if
a gas powered car has 2000 evs will have
about 200 but less mechanical parts
doesn't mean less problems evs have
complex electrical components like power
steering motors and high voltage relay
banks not to mention the giant battery
packs sitting below your feet the
battery pack is the most important part
of the vehicle and it's more expensive
than the motor itself the state of the
battery determines everything about your
car if you keep it out when it's too hot
or too cold it can get damaged if you
charge it too much the battery can die
an ev battery also has a lower
temperature operation range of 59 to 113
degrees fahrenheit as opposed to an
internal combustion engine which ranges
from -30 to 122 degrees fahrenheit the
components of an ev battery are also
highly flammable and it can start a fire
at almost any time manufacturers have
tried to fix the issue by separating the
battery into smaller cells with
firewalls to prevent thermal runaway
from occurring typically an ev battery
should last 10 years it loses its
capacity by about 2.3 percent every year
so you could still drive the car
normally but you'd have less and less
range as years go by replacing a tesla
model 3 battery is about 13
500 for a 75 kilowatt hour battery pack
and that's not including the fee for the
person who will replace it for you we're
not saying you have to learn to
dismantle a car and do it yourself but
for thirteen thousand five hundred
dollars you might have to range anxiety
and battery charging it's a problem they
have had from the start and it won't go
away until gm comes out with their
battery that is rated for a million
miles when swapping to an ev your range
is usually cut down by half or even more
and it doesn't help that cheaper evs
have a significantly lower range which
most drivers would struggle to get used
to in the past shockingly bad charging
times and ranges have made evs totally
unsuitable for anything other than trips
to work and back to get more range you'd
have to upgrade to a more expensive
model luckily the tesla supercharger
network has made it possible to charge
up to 80 percent in less than 40 minutes
but other ev companies continue to
struggle the thought of running out of
charge mid-journey and being stuck
somewhere for hours is what's coming to
be known as range anxiety more people
are now installing ev chargers in their
homes offices and malls but range
anxiety is hard to overcome when you're
planning a road trip but a 45-minute
break for coffee and stretching while
your ev charges up during a long journey
doesn't sound so bad but that's just in
the u.s what about the rest of the world
there is still a problem with public
charging in most countries and the
number of charges is only a small part
of the story in the uk a lot of the
public charging network in key highway
locations is run by ecotricity's
electric highway and a large percentage
of that is either ac which is equal to
level 2 charging in america or cha demo
dc which is great if you have something
like a nissan leaf but useless with most
modern evs there might be a lot of
chargers everywhere but they might not
be very good for topping up your car on
a long journey and a lot of them often
don't work either charge times and
charging stations are two of the biggest
challenges electric car companies face
right now access to high speed charging
is improving but if we're hoping to turn
all electric by 2030 there need to be
enough charging points to cure range
anxiety and charging problems lack of
choice looking for a new car is no
problem you can find a good one that's
within your budget sometimes you have to
haggle the price at a dealership and
drive away in your brand new car that's
if we're talking about an internal
combustion engine evs are
disproportionately aimed at the higher
end of the market there are few you can
get at a decent price but even those
don't give you the range you need a new
tesla will cost you nothing less than
forty thousand dollars and it will give
you a range of 263 miles prices could
fall in the future with tesla finding
better ways to refine their
manufacturing process and expand their
gigafactories worldwide but petrol and
diesel cars would still come cheaper
than evs
no one likes change the biggest issue
with the switch to evs is the lifestyle
change and limited educational resources
borrowing a friend's tesla for a day to
check it out won't give you an idea of
how it will be long term expecting to
roll up to a charging station and get
300 miles in five minutes is no longer
an option driving an ev requires a
serious lifestyle shift if you buy one
you need a clear idea of where your main
charging station will be the best
solution here is to get a home charger
so 99 of your journeys will be on home
power but that's obviously not possible
for everyone the truth is every new
technology has problems with gaining
acceptance and evs are no different evs
are not just about getting used to a
different lifestyle it has become a
topic of political and social debate
whether it's from climate change
skeptics fossil fuel vested interests or
those within the automotive industry the
concept of electric cars has only
recently started to gain serious
attention and acceptance what's more
most of the early attempts at electric
cars were so awful that many have
forever written them off in 2019 dyson
famously had to scrap its electric car
project because the vehicles were not
commercially viable in 2013 fisker
automotive went bankrupt after producing
the fisker karma one of the best luxury
hybrid electric vehicles there have been
many more failures along the way like
the gm ev1 and even the old sinclair c5
even tesla face defeat when its
collaboration with toyota for the rev4
ev failed so it might still be some time
before we see the widespread adoption of
electric vehicles conclusion so what do
you do abandon all hope well no if you
have the money to spare to go electric
choose an ev with enough range for your
everyday needs and create a charging
regime you need to have a much clearer
idea of where you can recharge and also
how fast those recharging spots are you
can even find apps that will locate the
closest station to you and give you that
information the main thing to understand
is it's not about whether evs are good
or bad overall but about how buyers
should do their research first and be
ready for the lifestyle and ev demands
prepare yourself to charge mostly at
home or have a routine of places to go
to shop exercise or eat that also
provide charging but most importantly
learn the best way to maintain your ev
so it doesn't run into problems and
account for service costs think you'll
buy an ev after knowing all this tell us
your thoughts in the comments below as
always if you enjoyed this video be sure
to hit the like button subscribe and
ring that bell so you never miss a video
from us thanks for watching